- Look at this.
- "Top Idol Match"?
It sounds like a variety program.
It was actually a plan for a TV show,
but if I can do it with you,
that'd be great.
In front of everyone, after the concert.
- I hope I don't get in the way.
- Of course you won't.
This concert is our chance
to pick a new member.
The bet is 50 million yen.
That's enough to get you out
of being a house pet, right?
- Yes.
- And...
if I win, of course,
your debt amount will increase.
And if that happens...
you'll form an idol unit with me.
I'll have your life plan changed
to reflect that.
I've even got a unit name.
It's "Dreaming Creaming Sisters"!
What?
We both have "yume,"
or "dream" in our names.
Don't you think that's fate?
But being an idol isn't always fun.
Lessons are hard,
and you don't have a private life.
And of course,
romance is out of the question.
You'll have to adjust
your whole life around being an idol.
I see.
But why are you so willing to be an idol?
Of course, for the smiles of my fans.
Don't lie to me.
You hate your fans, right?
What are you saying? That's impossible.
Oh, you're sure?
Then what is this?
Maybe I'll read a little!
"To my beloved Yumemi. Thanks for your
fun concerts! You always do a great job!
Lately, you've been so popular
on YourTube,
I'm very proud to head your fan club.
But as a long-time fan, I'm a little sad.
Lately, I've been busy studying,
but when I see how hard you're working..."
Enough!
Yumemi...
You're right.
So, what?
If you're continuing being an idol
even though you hate your fans,
you must have some kind of strong goal.
If I don't know what that is, then I...